[Music]
hey you guys
it's tuesday and look i have a jacket on
yeah it's cold today guess what i woke
up this morning it was 43 degrees
which is cooking another turkey too yeah
it smells really good at the house
i gotta drink turkey got a turkey for
four bucks you think i'm hoping
i think i'm gonna walk away from a
turkey for four dollars now we're gonna
have turkey again
well that's okay sick of turkey but i'm
gonna eat it i'm not sick of turkey i
never get sick of turkey
well because i don't even think i've had
because we didn't really have any good
bread so i don't even think i've had a
turkey sandwich
i got brand new rolls baked up from me
last night nice all right
so here's a ziploc bag i'm gonna have
like a whole bunch of like little turkey
sliders
i'm to make like a whole big plate of
them yeah
because i haven't eaten for like nine
hours got a new stuffing and everything
coming out
well [ __ ] all right yeah i didn't know
you were gonna like go whole hog i
thought i thought that stuff and i made
and i put that in the new turkey
so we have and i still got old stuff and
left but it doesn't matter we have so
much food in this [ __ ] house you guys
it's like not even funny
cornbread stuffing but yeah it's like
december 1st so it's like actually
southern [ __ ] man it's yeah so it's
actually like a [ __ ] winter and
yeah in florida and i made some new
cranberry sauce oh okay
yesterday you missed that i think yeah i
missed it yeah
i don't know what i was doing i just
wanted to get ahead i was gonna i knew i
was gonna do the turkey
another turkey today so i didn't want to
sit around [ __ ] around making all that
little [ __ ] so i did that
yesterday oh okay i didn't really all
the prep stuff yeah
okay well that's good yeah i'm gonna
chow down on that after this i gotta
make gravy though but i have old gravy
yeah and i'm like at all it's like four
days yeah so it was just from the other
day yeah
well and the thing is i'll probably just
have like sandwiches i don't like
need the whole you like gravy on a
sandwich no i put gravy in
and um well no because it makes the
bread all soggy no i do it right
i put gravy stuffing and um
cranberry on the [ __ ] sandwich well
yeah i know that but i don't want gravy
on the sandwich
i don't mind a little bit of stuffing on
there but let's make it like a little
bit of mayo and then like salt and
pepper
just put enough gravy just put enough
gravy on top of the dressing it kind of
mostly absorbs in there
like mayo yeah and then i put yeah never
mind
you're telling everybody what happened
let's see everybody's doing
hey everybody so yeah in there mangoes
out there
karen tammy everybody's here everybody's
here listen
louie's here yeah so we're uh
we actually ended up watching we were
gonna just gonna do one movie today but
we ended up watching two last night for
whatever reason
yeah um because the weird thing is that
there was a new one on netflix that i
wanted to watch which is that new
spanish movie don't listen so
we watched that and then you sprung it
on me that you're like oh hey i have
amazon prime
and i forgot about that i had that i
forgot
a movie back from 2012 like a horror
comedy so we watched that as well
i've been i had amazon prime going back
a couple months i was just
shopping with it oh okay and i found out
that
all i gotta do is download the damn
amazon prime video uh
your app for on the xbox one yeah for
the tv just like we have for hulu
there you go and then you can watch all
these [ __ ] movies for free a lot of
them
they're good prices yeah for the [ __ ]
but you know they got gemini man on
there we missed that one
um yeah we didn't see that they got
[ __ ] terminator woke fates in it
[ __ ] i call it woke fate what's it
really called dark fate
and then um they got the dr sleep
they got the [ __ ] director's cut
director's cut for the [ __ ] rambo
the new rambo ram but what's called
rambo uh
last blood yeah ram yeah rambo mexico
that's what it's called when he goes to
mexico
we'll call it rambo it would have been
funny if this was last blood if the one
before this had been called penultimate
blood that would have been like really
hilarious i would
call it last blood but they never really
sh did he really die i don't think i'm
not sure i'm not sure rambo actually
dies at the end of it
he can't die he's like jason voorhees
well look what they did with the [ __ ]
friday the 13th movies it's like it's
the last one it's the final chapter for
those but never mind no it's not yeah so
many recommended a movie he said it was
kind of like uh
said it was kind of like the frighteners
um i see where he's coming from where
it's kind of like the frighteners but
no not real it you know what it reminded
me most strongly of it actually reminded
me of do you remember that movie house
from 1986
a little bit which we should probably
review like one of these days because i
really like that movie with
i think we're going to recognize what
was in it are we going to talk about
this movie first it doesn't matter
we'll talk about this one first i can
see the idea is kind of like frighteners
and kind of like yeah yeah
but visually that and tonally it was
very different
um frighteners and house were definitely
moved period movies of the time you know
they were they were they were excuse me
not period movies but they were they
were movies of the period you know which
is 80s
and 90s and they kind of had a
spielbergian
feel to them this one doesn't this one
it uh to me it didn't have a whole lot
of a tone
didn't really have a distinct tone a lot
of the new movies feel this way to me
you know they're not really cinema
in my opinion well it seemed like
it seemed fairly low budget yeah that
said
it's like it was it's definitely more
comedy than horror
it's not like scary in the in the
slightest um
it did have like some good gags in it
particularly like in the first half i
think the first half was funnier than
the second half
it's mostly gags laugh a minute kind of
like it's trying to be a little bit more
like airplane
like that series or naked gun
a horror version of it but the edit
to me the the problem was it had a pond
very ponderous edit
and you'd sometimes forget what the
story was because they kept sidetracking
with these little gags
that's why it kind of felt to me yeah
the only
the only gag that i think went on too
long
was the one with the the poison brownies
like the brownies that had like the
sleeping pills in it that was like and
it was everybody was eating them like in
the
in the real estate office and like they
were all kind of so it's like so p
people probably like not know what we're
talking about so what this movie is
about it came out back in 2012 i'd never
actually heard of it um mango in the
comments
had actually recommended its time i
guess because it's on amazon prime so he
said oh i have amazon prime
it was free so yeah so we went ahead and
watched it and
um so it's basically it's about this guy
whose name is richard scary
just like the children's book author
which i thought was kind of funny
because i know that is but like the big
joke in the movie was like nobody knows
the [ __ ] that is
but um so he's a real estate agent and
him and his partner get essentially they
get sold this
kind of fixer-upper sort of house by
their
colleague who's kind of a taunt
and um like she was just trying to get
rid of it
and it ends up that it's like super
super haunted because it used to belong
to this
serial killer called what was he called
the sleep stalker or something like that
because he said that he would like kill
people to sleep and he didn't remember
and stuff
and so that um to the house is haunted
by like 12 ghosts
and the the ghosts are his victims and
they really don't waste any time in like
making their presence so like
so there's a lot of um amityville horror
gags in this like with the flies yeah
um the toilet like black [ __ ] coming out
of like the bleeding walls like that
kind of stuff
so there's all that kind of stuff in
there have to say um
i think the highlight of the movie for
me was barry bostwick
playing uh the priest that comes to do
the exorcism
because he just like leaned into it and
it was like
[ __ ] hilarious this kind of reminded
me of the
exorcist on an airplane movie that we
saw oh it wasn't that bad come on
that was pretty bad it's okay
the movie isn't bad i think i think a
lot of it needed to be trimmed out
it had it needed to be a little more
streamlined it
it didn't go from point a to point b
directly it didn't really take
what wasn't like a ride that was the
thing about
frighteners and say like back to the
future there's a certain
speed at which those tail with those
movies go
at you know what i mean there aren't any
slow spots in it
they don't have a scenes full filled
with gags like a scene just to have a
gag it's not really like that
the gags are kind of organic organic
they kind of happen
as the story starts to unfold another
thing is is that this movie looks
realistic in in a way it it
yeah it's not like artistically shot
right
and you know back to the future and
frighteners they don't really look
realistic
just the colors that are selected the
color palette just
shot composition and it's it's cinema
you know it it's drama
it's kind of stagey well it's like
heightened reality yeah like a
heightened reality so
it kind of has you know what i mean it
has a different
tone to it when you're going through it
and that's kind of what i look for
another thing is is that
the type of movies that i'm talking
about the kind of spielbergian or
something
or there's kind of like something out of
back to the future there was
even if the movie was had dark elements
in it
they were essentially very optimistic
movies
there was a sense of optimism and moving
forward
in in them and this movie kind of lacks
that
even though some of the gags were funny
it did not feel
optimistic you know what i'm talking
about kinda
i mean i didn't really get that as like
i said this
i will agree with you that the editing
was kind of slow even though it's not a
long movie i think it was only like 96
minutes or something like that
um a lot of the gags particularly in the
first half were funny
like i liked a lot of the homages to
like amityville horror
i loved barry bostwick's uh you know
character
him showing up i liked that like some of
the funny [ __ ] like between
um you know richard and his partner
richard and his mom who was like dying
of cancer
and she needed treatment which was one
of the reasons that he took on this
house even though he knew it was haunted
and his whole thing too was that for a
real estate agent
they were making the joke that he was
like too honest because real estate
agents you know obviously
you know who like to snow people um
you know or just like fudge the truth a
little bit you know just like to try to
sell you a house
and he's like too nice and too honest so
him knowing that the house is haunted
and trying to sell the house
while trying to not lie to anybody's
faces like about how haunted the house
is
um and then like after a while they just
start leaning into the haunting like
hoping that they're finding
that they'll find somebody that will
want to buy the house like that kind of
[ __ ] was funny
like i said when it got to like the
second half i felt like it dragged a
little bit
you know what i mean because it felt
like they were kind of trying to you
know
maybe pad the scenes out a little like
that one scene that was in the office
with everybody eating like the
the brownies that had the sleeping pills
in them it's like i feel like that could
have been like cut way down because it's
like that went on too long
um and also i think the the scene
between
him like being possessed by this one of
the spirits of the house or whatever
and then the the ghost blog girl
like them kind of like fighting and it's
like that probably could have been cut
down a little bit too
overall i thought it was like a pretty
it's not like
hilarious hilarious but it's like
amusing you know what i mean it's
the the humor is like not some of it's
like
shades into wacky but it's usually like
kind it was kind of low-key i thought
like a lot of the
gags in it were kind of low-key it's not
a bad movie but it's
i think it's just kind of four out of
ten you know five out of ten
yeah it was amusing yeah it was an
amusing movie like i said it reminded me
a lot of house from
1986 um probably not quite as good as
that well because house was like
crazy that had like all kind of [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] happening this one was
basically just ghosts and like
an amityville horror homage type of
thing um so you know so it was funny but
like
not i don't think i'd ever watch it
again though no titan tightening up the
edit adding a better score i think
probably would have been a lot better
shot composition lighting it had to have
kind of a
an unrealistic
look and feel to it the characters had
to be kind of larger than life
yeah because i think that was one of the
things that i liked about the
frighteners particularly the shots that
were
set in that one house you know what i
mean like where what's-her-face lived
where it looked like all gothic and it
was all kind of like so that was like a
really cool like look to it
another thing about that type of movie
from that era there was no there was
something kind of corporate
feeling about them yeah and
that didn't detract to it for me that
added to it
that it kind of had a corporate feeling
almost to him there's just no yeah i
guess you had to come up at the time
because that's the way that that's the
way everything kind of felt it's the way
the theaters felt
they gave a corporate feel to them you
know and it just kind of went along
you saw something as official well i
think that the i mean
obviously because of the difference in
you know the budgets between you know
yeah big studio movies and like indie
movies it was a lot more with the golf
was a lot wider
than it is nowadays because like
nowadays you can make a movie for really
cheap and it looks really good
right you couldn't really do that back
then right so i feel like there was a
lot there was a much larger distinction
between
you know this is a big official like you
said studio movie yeah that had like
millions of dollars behind it and this
was like an indie movie
you know what i mean that was kind of
like grotty looking yeah
so yeah that was kind of like that's
probably the main difference yeah yeah
this one like i said this one looked
totally turd
i didn't mean to say turn doesn't look
totally fine i was trying to say like
two words at once and it came out funny
um this one looked totally fine but it
wasn't like i said it wasn't
artistically staged or anything like
that it was just like very
workmanlike looking you know it's like
not cheap but you know you know
you know what's funny is i was looking
at the amazon prime they got vivarium up
there right
yeah it's getting like it gets like two
out of five stars like that movie is
[ __ ] bombing
the [ __ ] don't know what
they're looking at they don't know it's
one of them well you know what i've
sometimes
found not always but i've sometimes
found that the best movies or the movies
that i tend to like the best are ones
that are either like love them or hate
them yeah nobody seems to like that
movie you know what i mean
i did too and like i said that was one
of my favorite movies from last year
really cool science fiction movie that
was very unique
yeah well any time you make something
that's
weird like that you're going to get
people that would be like what the [ __ ]
yeah
what does that mean what does that mean
yeah
you know you're gonna get that it's
about child rearing
well like i said that's a scary part of
it it is kind of
yeah it's you know it has other things
too but it has like several layers
yeah you got [ __ ] aliens or like the
predator or some kind of [ __ ]
and it's making you raise its baby yeah
like you think of that that's a trip man
and uh
okay that's all i'm gonna say about it
well yeah because like i said we've
already reviewed that movie
and you talked about it on another
review too but um
yeah so went in the kung fu movie and
the kung fu movie yeah you probably
you probably talked about artist self
defense more than yeah yeah
those are masterpieces jesse eisenberg
masterpieces
yeah you gotta you gotta have some [ __ ]
about you to [ __ ] appreciate
masterpieces like that
just something about those all right so
the other movie we watch we actually
watch the selling second we watch this
one first but it doesn't really matter
whatever
so this one was one that i had seen come
up on a lot of um
review channels that i watch uh because
netflix just added it a couple days ago
this is a spanish film
now the english title is don't listen
even though the spanish title is voces
or voices um you know obviously
which uh to me seems like a better name
i don't know if i guess they called it
don't listen over here because maybe
they're trying to associate it with
don't breathe
even though that's it's nothing to do
with that movie i don't know
but so this is a spanish movie and it's
about this
family and the dad daniel
he's like um a house flipper so
they bought like this creepy old house
like out in the wilds of spain somewhere
and that's he they don't know this until
later but
i guess in the town it's called like the
house of the voices and they have this
little boy who's nine named eric
and he says that he starts hearing
voices like people are like telling him
to do things
or they're like talking through his
radio um and [ __ ] like that and it gets
like super creepy
and as it goes on i don't really want to
spoil too much about this one like i
said this
is it's not it's it's kind of your
standard
haunted house type of thing had some
like uh insidious kind of vibe to it
that type of [ __ ] but i will say that
two things that happened in this movie
one like pretty early in the film
and the other thing like at the end of
the film um
i did not expect them so it kind of like
it actually did a good job of like
you know messing with my expectations
so um i don't your mileage may vary
maybe i'm just stupid and like i didn't
but i like the [ __ ] that happened i
didn't really see it coming
but i mean it's a pretty standard like
haunted house story like you get
some bad [ __ ] happens and then they have
to bring in like the paranormal
investigator and the paranormal
investigator's daughter and they're
trying to like figure out
you know turkey oh yeah what the [ __ ] is
going on in this house
and uh you know it's got some jump
scares and [ __ ] like that it doesn't
really rely on them
but i really really liked like the
atmosphere of this one
and even though like at first i was like
well it's a little bit slow but i kind
of like
you know how it's going and i like some
of the imagery that they had because
like the old house was super creepy and
all this other kind of [ __ ] they also
had some flies in this one too now that
i'm thinking about it
but um so i really liked the way it was
going
and then it seemed like as it went on
it seemed like it got better and better
like it got creepier and creepier like
as it went on
which i thought was cool because
sometimes like you know horror movies
like this will kind of like lose steam
toward the end
but i thought it actually got better as
it went on because
the story kind of got deeper and then
like at the very very end it went like
in a direction that i
totally wasn't expecting uh it's
possible too that they could be setting
up
i don't know if they're gonna set up
like another movie or they're trying to
do like a conjuring universe type of
thing with this paranormal investigator
guy who was
now didn't it say in the you said in the
credits that it was cesar romero yeah
and i was like
is it that season i didn't know it was
that's like i thought i figured that
you'd be dead by now i thought that dude
was dead
he had to be dead i mean that might be a
common name in spain i don't really know
like he's a [ __ ]
that's what he said i mean there was an
old like the paranormal investigator was
like an old guy but i was like i don't
think he was that old
i think caesar was [ __ ] in his 50s
back in the 1960s i meant to look it up
and i totally forgot i didn't say you
just saw it in the credits yeah he's got
it
yeah he's got to be this just has to be
another maybe it's his son or
something like that i don't really know
but um but yeah so i i feel like they
might be
maybe gonna do like a conjuring universe
thing like with this old guy
who's like a paranormal investigator and
he has a daughter named ruth and she
like kind of works with him sometimes
even though she's kind of a skeptic
although you know spoiler alert in this
movie this she's like okay
but a ghost exists here he said caesar
romero died in 94.
yeah i thought it had been like a long
time so it can't be the same guy like i
don't know if he's related or
well george jones asked me how does a
goal feel about these movies
i figured we'd have to go into the
stephen cigal thing but yeah if you have
netflix and you liked
like insidious or you like like other
kind of spanish movies kind of like
atmospheric kind of like has a couple
i will say that there is a very
upsetting scene in it um
if you if you love the kitties yeah i i
was really kind of bothered by that
scene
um but yeah that was kind of horrifying
but uh yeah so uh let's let's weigh in
let's weigh in steven seagal oh okay
what do you have to say
well the first movie was about ghosts
and of course i like ghosts because it
has to do with eastern
eastern philosophies the energy of chi
energy is not destroyed it just
transfers into something else
so of course when i die i'm going to be
a ghost same as everybody
else except my ghost will be better than
all your ghosts
my ghost will [ __ ] your ghosts up
[Laughter]
so that's why so i kind of liked the
first one
it wasn't very serious though
and they were killing people i don't
like to kill people in my movies
i have other people kill people in my
movies
like my stunt dog
second movie was all right but it didn't
have explosions in it
that's true and it needed a car chase
hand me that asian experience
[Laughter]
well now the one movie i don't know if i
don't know if you were which order you
were talking about them in but the one
movie that
the first one the spanish one that
didn't have a car chase it did however
have like a really horrible car accident
yeah in which a woman gets impaled
through the head with a tree branch
[Laughter]
so you know it had that going for it
also the ghost and it looked really
really creepy i like i really really
liked the
the ghost that they had in it but yeah
it was a cool ass movie did you know
that i'm an expert in shiatsu
yeah i've heard that yeah i i find
breast cancer lumps for free
yeah i've heard that as well do you have
a business card i'll give you an
inspection later
okay see if we can find some lumps
i can't believe he like actually did
that did he like seriously
yeah i mean because more than one person
has come out and said that they said
that he said that right
every girl that met him [ __ ] said
that he offered to [ __ ] help help
check her for breast cancer that's my
god
using shiatsu it's like
he's always full to
i manipulate i found something in there
i mean [ __ ] man that's like [ __ ] that
like drunk frat dudes at a bar
are like smart enough not to try like
because they'll get
so the fact that he thought he could get
away with that oh my god
fourth draw down says seagal has an
achilles butt
oh my god that's awesome one of those
wrestlers
i forgot what his name was freddie
something or other
put him in a headlock [ __ ] put him in a
sleeper hole knocked him out evidently
and
a turd slipped out of [ __ ] uh uh out
of [ __ ] cigar
i've heard that story too i hope that's
true anybody
danny baduchi or whatever his name is
saying about it yeah
danny about douchey some kind of [ __ ]
guido name
that was the guy that was the kid that
he used to be on
[ __ ] what [ __ ] show was he the
partridge family right i think it was he
was on the partridge family
and then he got older and then he beat
up a transsexual
yeah i think i don't remember somebody i
think right somebody in the comments
section i can't remember what kind of
whole thing
somebody in the comment section might
remember who it was i was talking about
yeah
yeah so yeah you left that oatmeal cream
pie yeah over there
it's like he brought one time
[Laughter]
sure steve um yeah he brought that
two of them in here one time when we
were doing the main show and he was like
really really drunk
and he bought he brought two in here and
then he ate one and then he never ate
the other one and it's still sitting
there
like a week and a half later because i
don't like him yeah you guys do you guys
remember who that was that [ __ ]
the gall out and a turd slipped out of
him that wasn't danny bonaduce
i don't think that was that other guy i
[ __ ] forgot his name
i can't remember his name either i think
when we did the steven seagal show i did
look that up because i thought that
story was really funny and like i
i remember somebody said telling that
story like on harold
or something well of course you're gonna
deny it nobody wants to be the person
that like pooped their pants in front of
everybody
he evidently i can't remember what it
was he said he had a way
to prevent himself from being knocked
out in a chokehold or something yeah
that he could resist it that only like
you know yeah because of course he had
to go to like
people that really fight and was like oh
i have this you know secret
super secret like method he probably
thought he could just he could tense his
[ __ ] throat in which case everybody's
just gonna be like oh yeah
i'm signing up for this [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] funny and then they punch him he
poops his pants
that's just what happens allegedly
[Laughter]
yeah now he wasn't a bodybuilder i don't
think i think he was a wrestler
i thought he was a wrestler he was a
wrestler and he was training he was at
the time he was an old wrestler he was
being a trainer at the time
yeah it was all again at the time he was
training people for ms foreign
that's it he was training he was trained
he was a trainer he was training [ __ ]
mma guys yeah yeah that's right
yeah he's older puts the gun ahead like
[ __ ] knocked it well don't go around
to like some
yeah don't go around to some like
[ __ ] wrestling trainer and be like oh
i have a way to like keep
because everybody's gonna be like oh
okay i'm gonna put you right in that
chokehold and we're gonna test that out
yeah it was i mean and then the fact
that the turd slipped out that was just
like
icing on the cake you know if that part
really happened
like i said allegedly the bell happened
he said he said he said it happened so
you could smell it
well i would believe gene labelle before
i would believe steven seagal
yeah and like i said steven seagal has
more incentive to lie because nobody
wants to be the person that pooped their
pants in public
right yeah i mean you know you can't
blame him for not for lying about it
yeah i'd probably live at it too if it
happened to me
[Laughter]
he was talking about it on [ __ ] joe
rogan's show
yeah i think i saw that clip actually
yeah yeah
she went viral so that's part of the
reason why seagal moved russia
then [ __ ] that if like i'm trying to
escape all those charges
well everybody's probably gonna make fun
of him over there
[Laughter]
they have the internet over there it's
like everybody's seen the same [ __ ]
he met putin and he talked his way into
putin to meet and putin and
[ __ ] putin's like who is this like
what's his
stinky fat dude out of my office
[Laughter]
putin was impressed with his ability to
[ __ ]
yeah i could say that yeah mango says
seagal runs that way because the turtle
is poking out of his ass
get that turtle head you gotta poke that
back in there that's what you know what
i mean it's like when you're running to
the bathroom you don't think you're
gonna make it yeah
i gotta end this show man i got turkey
enough all right we gotta go get the
turkey out of the oven
[Laughter]
turds and [ __ ] turds and turquoise
turtle turd
turkles
[Laughter]
so uh yeah we we will find something to
watch on amazon prime tonight probably
and we'll be
actually tomorrow we'll probably see
gemini man because we because i can't
see that one
yeah i kept seeing the damn trailer and
then we just never got around to
watching it bombed but i don't think
it's because it was a bad movie i think
a bomb because [ __ ] that was the time
when [ __ ]
covid was starting to happen and [ __ ]
yeah movie theaters were all going out
of business
i swear to god you people man this is
the [ __ ] apocalypse it's like the
[ __ ]
they're calling it the great reset they
got all these [ __ ] and
funny ass clothes behind it over in
germany ex-nazi [ __ ]
reset and everything and we ain't gonna
be in the reset they're trying to kill
us
i think they're definitely trying to
kill me they don't want dudes like me
around
[ __ ] let's stop them okay yeah me and
millions other
we ain't gonna have this [ __ ] [ __ ]
where we just standing
and bubble like like we i'm getting sick
of being in here man [ __ ] we gotta
have some cool [ __ ] to do
i'm in the [ __ ] bubble like the
matrix they're gonna put vr goggles on
give me some kind of [ __ ] cyber job
yes
i just sit around get bed sores living
in a down virtual reality
and the pod that i'm in is [ __ ] being
run by my body heat and then they just
[ __ ] feed me iv [ __ ]
just like i'm [ __ ] the matrix they
say that's just green that's energy
efficient that's what they're gonna do
yeah we'll see all right so we gotta go
eat some turkey because i'm [ __ ]
starving yeah
and i thought you were gonna end the
show and then you just kept on talking
okay
all right so we will back tomorrow uh to
talk about another movie so
thanks everybody for dropping by have a
good rest of your day and uh we'll see